[Music]
anime has no shortage of overpowered
characters or someone who's just strong
in a way that puts you in awe it's fun
to have power level debates and all but
seriously comparing these freaks of
nature with each other is nothing short
of a herculean task so instead i want to
dedicate this video to talking about
them and what i like about either them
or their shows today i'll be looking at
my top 10 favorite overpowered main
characters in anime but before anything
let's take some time to thank today's
sponsors counter-side counterside is an
anime-style mobile rpg from studio
b-side where the players take the role
of a ceo who recruits counters with
special powers to fight against monsters
that threaten the world now the first
thing that stands out to me for
counter-side is the quality of the
graphics the whole 2d anime feel is
exactly my jam and the urban fantasy
setting is the cherry on top it also has
an immersive story that puts it well
above a lot of its peers in the anime
rpg genre and yes this is a gacha game
but what isn't a gacha game these days
the most important part is the gadget is
quite generous you get a lot of free
rolls the rates are pretty nice and the
game isn't made in a way that makes
every banner character a must-have this
is one of the most free to play friendly
games i've ever played and that's saying
something considering how many of these
anime s gatcha games i've played
pre-registration is available so if you
want to be the first in line and get
some exclusive benefits don't waste any
time in registering you can use the
following promo code to get in-game
rewards hope to see you join the fun
soon
starting things off is right
remember back when we got those korean
webtoon adaptations those were the days
among the three of them nobles doesn't
have the most stand out reputation
however if there's one thing that the
anime showcase decently it's how
overpowered its main character the
reawakened vampire rye is throughout the
show he got a lot of opportunity to
showcase his strength for me the most
memorable one would be the battle
against clan leaders it's the
culmination of him establishing how far
above everyone he is he just played with
all of them throughout and this fight is
even better in the source material
the second character on the list is mob
at first glance mom doesn't give the
impression of an overpowered character
at all he's super plain in terms of
appearance and as a character there's
nothing brooding or loud about him none
in the two opposites of character
impressions don't be fooled this is one
of the most powerful psychics of them
all i like mob because he's not just all
about the op in fact much of the story's
drama is about him and his emotions how
he forms a dynamic with the world around
him and how he channels that energy to
become the hero that he is still let's
give credit to the powers because
they're insane some of his battle modes
come with the most spectacular
animations people have known in the
world of anime and i think that it helps
carry the scenes and drive that point
home maybe you're playing everyday guy
at first glance but underneath that
socially awkward personality is one of
the most powerful psychics of all
[Applause]
next in line is tatsuya from mahoka
[Music]
you have a protagonist who's supposed to
be one of the lower tier students but it
turns out he might as well be god in a
high school student's body genius
engineer top class fighter and plane
immortal that so yet seems to be a lot
of these and the entirety of mahogan
seems to be episode after episode of
driving that point hope this is a guy
who can heal lethal wounds in a matter
of seconds bring people back to life
analyze everything mid-battle and come
out on top with his trusty handguns
people have given him the moniker
godzilla and it's not hard to see why
don't get ready to leave the school
setting just yet because goro sensei is
up next
[Music]
in contrast to the stoic attitudes of
the previous entries koro sensei comes
off as jovial he's an upbeat character
with a lot of absurd requests but don't
let the childish facade for you there's
a reason why the entire premise of
assassination classroom is to kill him
it's because it's nigh on impossible
gono-sensei has shown to be near
impervious to everything and is filled
to the brim with weapons often in places
she'd least expect them and that's not
even getting to the superhuman
intelligence senses and speed all trades
befitting someone who was the world's
greatest assassin at some point in his
life well he does have his share of
weaknesses but those are mostly
psychological and barely affected
showing us the reaper crossing him is
something you never ever want to do
[Music]
the fifth character i want to talk about
is alucard
[Music]
i've had a lot of fun talking about
helsinki anyway it's the perfect western
oriented anime in the 2000s dark gritty
violent it's those hardcore things that
appeal to a lot of the people wanting a
dash of edgy coolness in their lives and
alucard is the personification of those
elements dressed in his guard with
matching shades alucard is nothing short
of cool the cherry on top of course is
the sheer overpoweredness of the
character a lot of helsing is dedicated
to him just decimating the opposition in
the most over-the-top manner possible
all while holding back if multiple
showcases of power weren't enough you
can try seeing him at his peak level
zero arlu guard is horror incarnate and
a true sight to behold and hey if you
like what you're seeing so far don't
hesitate to hit that like and subscribe
button
coming up now is psyche
[Applause]
in a lot of ways psyche reminds me of
mob the similarities are just uncanny
given that they both have psychic powers
and have personalities that remind me of
each other they also have a desire for
attracting people despite their
reservations just way more pronounced in
the case of psyche and they're both
crazy op it's just not as visually
stunning in the case of psyche because
he's in a comedy show still that doesn't
take away from the insanely large
arsenal psyche has when it comes to
putting his psychic powers into action
he can practically do anything with his
powers and fans can attest to that it's
really a joy to see psyche's cynical
attitude create an interesting dynamic
with the people around him add that to a
lot of over-the-top shenanigans and you
have a winner for one of the best
comedies the anime world has given us
the sixth character on the list
daily life of immortal king is one of
the more niche titles around so i
wouldn't be surprised if it's the show
that you're the least familiar with out
of the things i've talked about so far
still it's one of the most honest in
terms of titles that sell the main
character because it easily sets
expectations the immortal wang ling is
one of the most powerful main characters
in anime for the most part wang ling
wants nothing more than to have a normal
life that's been the trend with a lot of
these characters right just like psyche
he just can't seem to stay out of
trouble however in contrast to said
character wang ling has powers far
beyond human comprehension the
immortality is a thing but how about
reality warping add that to the
superhuman feats and you have a virtual
god whose skills have been honed after
constant reincarnation abilities that he
tries oh so hard to keep in check daily
life of immortal king is a fun show and
all but it's also quite neat and appeals
strongly to a particular audience if you
want someone out for a bit of chinese
anime that features the overpowered
protagonists the cultivation genres
become notorious for you can try this
one out for size
right that was the seventh entry in so
eight on my list is heinz
you can point to many things to make a
case for irons to be one of the most
overpowered protagonists of all time it
could be how easily he beat the
strongest enemies it could be how he
nonchalantly eradicates entire armies
with a spell whatever it is he's here to
stay in the conversation for good it's
understandable how hard it is at times
to see past the intimidating skeleton
appearance of the stoic facade all while
irons acts like a super villain out to
conquer the world but he's more than
that and his loyalty and charisma have
attracted many denizens of idris hill to
his side beyond that shadow of an
all-powerful ruler also lies a human
side one that he hadn't let go of that
in my opinion makes it one of the best
characters i've talked about so far or
maybe it's just me finding that
sympathetic side past that scary
non-human form to be very cool
[Music]
[Music]
just like rye anos is a supernatural
being awakened after a long hiatus
trying to come to terms with the world
that's passed him by with arnos he
wastes absolutely no time in making a
first impression from the moment he had
his first fight with that cocky guy in
the first episode i already knew what we
were getting for the most part it is
what it is he just shows how vastly
superior he is compared to everyone else
in the show but i also find myself
immersed in the show because how he goes
about solving problems that can't just
be brute forced people call misfit of
demon king academy the one punch man of
magic academy anime but i think it's a
little more than that come and give this
show a shot
and topping off the list who else the
site armor
here's the actual one punch man what i
love about the show is that for starters
it hooks you on a simple premise one
hero trained so hard until he became
able to be everything in one punch
simple premise simple show right
wrong i could talk a lot about the
intricacies and the unexpected depth
from one punch man but we're here in an
overpowered characters list so let's
focus on the main character saitama well
there isn't much to say for saitama it
is what it is one punch villain goes
bye-bye the cool thing about saitama
though is how creative and funny some of
those one-punch wins are the sonic fight
comes to mind you see while others like
the genos fight are remarkably awesome
overall saitama is a cool character
who's very fun to watch much of it has
to do with his personality on how he
shifts from indifferent to serious to
comedic one punch man is a parody of the
overpowered hero aspects of shows and if
you're up for some laughs and some
serious feels make sure to check saitama
out in his own habitat
and that's my list of overpowered main
characters who's your favorite op main
character make sure you comment below if
you're up for some more interaction you
can check out the discord link below as
well as drop by the channel's patreon
and instagram pages don't forget to
check out our sponsors game counter side
take it from me this is a gadget game
the anime fans should absolutely try
that's it for this video and thank you
for watching hope to see you again